hello I'm Tilda and i'm here today to
talk about pivoting to react at scale
some things i'll be covering are an
overview of the architecture choices we
made it Pinterest things that went well
things that did not go so well and high
level conclusions it is the way of the
world of front-end that you are going to
be pivoting your web framework every two
to five years as Amy pointed out in her
awesome talk yesterday the joy and the
pain of javascript is that there are a
lot of different ways to do the same
thing and your conventions are in flux
that leads us to have more paradigm
shifts pivot more frequently when i
first started at Pinterest in 2013 my
very first project was finishing the
pivot from a django app to a django app
with backbone on top of it it was pretty
painful because the last twenty percent
of that rewrite took eighty percent of
the time of the project so this time
around we wanted to think a little
better be a little smarter about it in
order to know where we going we have to
think about where we've been so I picked
2013 because that was the last time we
did a significant pivot in 2013 web
development was very different jquery
was the most common paradigm of the day
we had a bunch of competing platform
work such as amber angular react was
just starting to enter the scene and
cross-platform compatibility was
definitely a headache so in 2013 we had
an app that was built on top of backbone
and Django architecture kind of looked
like this was built on top of Jango's
middle
which is not I don't think Django strong
suit but would have we had a Python
router we had Python resources which are
like a wrapper around the API and we had
modules modules are little reusable
composable bits of HTML CSS and
JavaScript so they compose our whole
entire tree how many of you have worked
on kind of like a Frankenstein app like
this where do you had like different
pieces of things glued together yeah you
know what I'm talking about kind of
sucks huh I mean it was okay for what it
was but there are problems even on a
fast connection on a fast machine like
scrolling the Pinterest grid was kind of
janky we got called out for having some
of the most bloated CSS of any big
website and we had to maintain to
rendering code paths we were server-side
rendering in Python which you have to
server-side renderer SEO and we're
client side rendering in JavaScript
maintaining those two was not fun so
2016 rolls around and react is
definitely kind of the winning the
framework more at least for right now
and it's pretty easy to see why if you
take functional programming concepts and
apply them to front end it eliminates a
whole class of bugs that you see if
you're like making assumptions about the
state of your Dom and writing a period
of code plus it's extremely fast so it
was a pretty logical choice react isn't
the only thing that's changed though we
have es6 giving us the spread operator
arrow functions and classes all that
sweet sweet syntactic sugar to make
JavaScript more of a joy to write we
have better support and tooling for node
and we have Babel and web pack so we can
just transpile all the things and not
worry so hard about supporting different
browsers so right now this is kind of
what the Pinterest architecture
looks like we've got a node process
talking to the Python API and we have
both denzel modules and react components
why both well once you get to pinterest
scale pivoting your app takes a while
but what do I even mean by at scale it
is such an overloaded term the context
that I'm setting here is at scale means
source lines of code and numbers of
developers I was really surprised to
find out that we have almost 500 k lines
of code in our web app alone and that's
not including node modules or blank line
I also I discovered that we have a
hundred and sixty for web developers
based on the highly scientific method of
seeing how many people are hanging out
in the web rooms of slack so given that
we're even bigger now than we were last
time we pivoted how could we go about
this in a smart way what in doubt just
you know go back to the the basics the
building blocks of computer science data
structures and algorithms so what kind
of data structure is a web application
most like well it's a tree what kind of
algorithms do we have for changing
things in trees you could either start
at the root and walk down or you can
start at the bottom and walk up we chose
starting at the bottom and walking up in
order to have a forcing function to make
everyone convert things over as if we
allowed people to just kind of start in
the middle and render denzel modules
from inside of react if they could start
anywhere in the tree they would not be
motivated to port everything over they'd
rewrite the cool fun sexy things that
give you a boost and then ignore all the
other cruft and we be maintaining two
worlds forever we didn't want that those
kind of a high level what we did now I'm
going to dive down a little bit into the
Nitty Gritty of things that went well
so what do you get to pinterest sighs
you had a bunch of teams like let's say
we have about ten teams writing web code
all those teams have different metrics
that they care about every team we had
them wrapped their features and
individual experiments so we could
measure the gains we've got which is
really motivating both for individual
developers and for management to
continue to understand why react should
be a priority we got some really sweet
gains let's talk conversion numbers does
anybody want to take a guess on the
percentage improvement we got in
conversion rates from switching our pin
page to react oh come on i don't have
candy anyone have a guess thanks Ted no
not quite but ten percent that's pretty
good and five point six percent on
interest pages we also recently ported
the profile page over it dropped average
time to first interaction by 22% the ten
percent increase in pageviews was for
profile pages then there are also other
downstream effects like which makes
sense because people look at the profile
page it loads pretty fast and they're
like sweetie I'm going to click on some
other stuff we got a seven percent
increase in international sessions and a
one percent increase in overall sessions
the bigger increase internationally
makes a ton of sense because those users
were undoubtedly hurting the most from
our crappy latency before another thing
we did is we shimmed backbone before we
even started porting to react we took
backbone and made it so that we had
eighty percent of the functionality but
it didn't have the dependencies that it
had before that were quite bloated like
jQuery and underscore this allowed us to
significantly reduce the size of our
bundle and still be able to run Denzel
we also updated Denzel to use
declarative states
imperative to declarative is a pretty
big mental shift that we're asking
developers to make and react is a big
change too so by decoupling those
changes and giving people a sequence to
learn things in it's a little less of a
cognitive load so this is a mistake that
we made in Denzel that we did not make
and react your designers are going to
want to pivot how the website looks
every two years too because that's just
the world that they're in their trends
and visual design as well and it is so
tempting to be like well if we have to
rewrite everything anyway we might as
well just you know change how it looks
but don't do it the reason why is
because with Denzel we had all these
metrics drops that were super hard to
debug it was like our users interacting
with this page differently because it
looks different or is there actually a
bug in here somewhere we made the same
mistake with our iOS rewrite recently I
don't know what we were thinking but
with react we said no and it was much
smoother so when you have 164 people how
do you make sure that everybody stays on
the same page people have different
learning styles some people are visual
learners some people are verbal learners
so we have to cater to everybody for
people who prefer email there is an
email list web platform announced and
then we had a slack bot that you could
invite into your channel and get those
same updates if that's how you roll for
people that prefer in person there was
regular office hours that anyone could
come and ask questions sewer get
debugging help and we had a wiki page as
well which is really important
especially for women or other
underrepresented minorities or people
who statistically speaking are going to
be less comfortable asking questions so
it's one thing to put the information
out there and tell people what kind of
things you expect to them but how do you
actually make sure that they're writing
code that meets your conventions Lynch
all the things react is particularly
suited to linting because the output of
jsx is an object that you can easily
inspect and be like oh hey this image
doesn't have an alt tag and that's
really important for accessibility we
open sourced our linter configuration
and I would also encourage you to check
out this es Lin jsx accessibility plugin
if you care about accessibility and you
should okay so that was what went well
here things that I might do differently
next time around I don't know about you
but learning a new framework is
sometimes hard scary especially with
react there's like not just react itself
but all this other stuff around it I
dived in and I was trying to learn EO 6
+ j sx and react and an p.m. and i was
like I don't know what I'm doing if I
had to do this again I would put a
suggested order of learning operations
on the wiki so that people who are
junior or more just new to web or
whatever have a way to sequence their
learning and not get overwhelmed I agree
with Pete hunt that this is a pretty
good learning order and you might not
even need all this stuff depending on
the size and complexity of your app so
as I mentioned before we force people to
convert from the leaf nodes up in order
to make sure that they would port
everything over but there is a use case
we missed that was kind of a duh which
is like people were going to want to add
entirely new page types that didn't
exist inside Denzel we were able to get
it working
it was a little bit hacky and it would
have been better to invest some time in
thinking about that up front we also
kept the HTML structure of the pages
exactly the same disallowed our
measurements to be a true
apples-to-apples comparison however it
also meant that we had to write more
code to keep up with shitty practices
from the old system we didn't have a
great plan for data flow out of the box
we were like just you set state but when
you have an appt with a deeply nested
component structure then you fed to data
and you're passing it down from child to
child the child these days we have we're
using redux and we have a higher order
component that fetches data so it's much
easier and we should have set that up
straight out of the box a mistake that
denzel made was coupling data fetching
and rendering in the same function the
reason why that's a no-no is because it
allows developers just kind of gloss
over performance problems by pretending
there isn't a loading state well there
is a loading state and you need to deal
with it when you're writing react
components you need to think about what
your components going to look like when
there's no data the reason that this
impacted our rewrite or made it harder
was because of people are porting over
there Denzel components they had to
think about things like loading state
that they hadn't previously considered
we did not set up our testing frameworks
soon enough and consequently our unit
test coverage has suffered a little bit
once developers of ship things and the
code is in the wild you are not going to
get people to go back and write unit
tests it is not going to happen if i
want to known how easy it is to use
enzyme and just this would have gotten
set up a lot sooner in fact i'd even go
so far as to say the true value of react
is testability not speed
there are tools down so that you can
render a string to a dom node and
different and it's still fast but not
nearly as testable finally we didn't
have a good CSS strategy that was semi
intentional because we were already
changing so much stuff we didn't want to
change everything all at once in
overwhelmed people but the thing about
writing react is that it makes it
immediately obvious like global CSS is a
bad idea in the same way the global
variables are a bad idea because we
didn't provide teams with clear
guidelines on what to do it was kind of
like the wild wild west some people were
using bens style some people are using
inline styles we're in the process of
cleaning that up and moving to CSS
modules and it's going to be great but
we're not there yet so at a high level
what did what did we learn from this the
more you can irritably update the
semantics of your old system to match
the new system the easier your rewrite
is going to be now we did a little bit
of this with backbone light and with
updating denzel to use declarative
states but we could have gone way
further with it for example we could
have updated backbones life cycle
methods to match reacts component
lifecycle methods so how is code like
DNA did you know that the kind of
nutrition that your grandmother got when
she was pregnant with your mother
impacts your birth weight and your
health throughout your life this is not
it's not even because of DNA it's
because of epigenetic markers so in the
same way the code you write it and then
you run it DNA is written we'll just
call it written and then it's run your
body runs it and turns it into you
epigenetic markers are like meta code
that tell your body
to run your DNA or how to how your genes
should be expressed like a rewrite
they're passed down from generation to
generation so it's epigenetic markers
that deal with the fetal nutrition stuff
that I just mentioned your rewrite the
choices you make now impact not only
this rewrite or not only the next
rewrite but the following one after that
fundamentally engineering is about
making trade-offs so when you go
pivoting your app choose your own
adventure and choose wisely thank you